we see ourselves oftentimes as as doing
something beneficial whereas that's not
what is being perceived by whatever
species is doing their thing so the
first story that i'm going to
essentially tell you about is this the
story where there's extraterrestrial
beings who are considered part of the
universal immune system now if you have
a species that is behaving like a
bacterial infection then it gets
targeted by the immune system of the
universe at large at the same time as
you have an extraterrestrial being who's
like you know what there's so much value
in humanity we can make humanity choose
so even they are playing into this
choice point where you've got you know
these extraterrestrial beings who are
trying to prove that
the human race is essentially gone rogue
and is a cleanup species meaning it's
what we have to take out of the picture
of the rest of the system because the
amount of collective asking from earth
planting the mineral kingdom animal
kingdom that are asking for us to go is
huge it's like a
signal throughout the universe
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you very much for coming and
you're in for a treat today today i have
teal swan on the show she is an
international speaker she is a
best-selling author and her mission is
to transform human suffering to an
empowered and authentic life man i mean
she has an incredible youtube presence
she really speaks to the human
experience in a way that i don't know
anybody does her understanding of it and
her ability to put it into words and
use examples so that
we regular humans can understand these
aspects of ourselves and this experience
of being human in a way to help us
progress and evolve and step out of
suffering and to understand the
experience more it's it's incredible i
recommend anybody watch her on youtube
she has a huge youtube channel tons of
videos anything that you could possibly
want to watch a video and she has it it
was tough for me today in the episode to
be able to speak to a lot of new things
because she literally like covers
everything and i've watched so much
content but we did we got into some
areas that i've not heard or speak about
before but of course we did talk about
relationships we talked about the human
experience we just started off with what
is love right the simple question
we talked about what we're here for
talked about source energy and how that
plays into our experience as humans
talked about extraterrestrials it's
basically like if you've never heard of
this before you could look it up it's
basically like talking to the akashic
records live and in person
which means it's
basically the information of everything
thank you so much for coming thank you
for watching if you like what you see um
and you enjoy these episodes please make
sure that you click the subscribe button
so that you'll get notifications for
when more of these fun fun episodes come
out
i'm very excited when jen said she's
like i think we have teal on the hook a
little and i was like are you serious i
was like she's like i thought you might
like that i'm like i don't like that i
love that
[Music]
i have been listening to you for a
really long time and
it's um
the way that you put things and the
clarity and the examples you use it's
just
it's kind of second to none to a lot of
people out there that are trying to
explain
the human experience
thank you
does that come naturally to you yeah why
do you think it's so natural
you know
i'm a really really highly intellectual
person
you know
we've got these different qualities
things like wisdom things like intellect
my intellect level is like really really
high and that makes it a lot easier i
think to dissect things
and also it helps to be able to
visually see in somebody's energy field
whether they're getting something or not
and that helps you to kind of make micro
adjustments for the sake of
understanding
wow
well that's amazing because you're
are you making are you able to make
adjustments for a collective
understanding of what topic okay not
just like the like for instance me if
i'm getting it but a collective audience
yep
can you tell how big the collective
audience is as well
i mean depends what i'm working with but
often yeah
fascinating i thought that the first
thing we'd start off with is something
really sweet and lovely and about your
book coming up which is called how to
love yourself
which i think sounds like an incredible
remedy for just about everything in the
world going on perhaps so i thought i'd
start off with just kind of like a big
question and just ask first off what is
what is love
okay love is to take another as a part
of oneself we of course don't really
have that understanding of love even
though that's essentially what's
happening when we feel love
because we like to confuse that word
with so many different states and i
think one of the hardest parts about
the english language is that we're just
so limited you know
the word love in other cultures they
usually have so many other words for it
you know so you can start to
differentiate between you know what love
as a concept is versus what this
romantic love is versus what this
friendship love is so that's part of why
we get so lost in the weeds especially
in the western culture so to take
another as a part of oneself so that
there is essentially no
no genuine separation
is what love is and all of these things
we see as a byproduct of love are just a
byproduct of taking the other as a part
of the self so like when we do that when
we take somebody as a part of ourselves
their best interest is no longer ins
like separable from our best interests
so it's not possible then to act against
that person without wounding ourselves
at the same time which is what makes
beauty their love so beautiful
and it naturally gives rise to things
like trust
you know so usually when somebody says
you know i've fallen out of love with
you or i don't feel like you love me
right now it's because
they don't feel like they're being taken
as a part of the other person they feel
instead like in that relationship
there's a separation which is making it
so both they and the other person are in
what we call an ego state
they perceive themselves to be separate
and so they can start to play a zero-sum
game
you know where i can act in my best
interest regardless of what's in your
best interest
and then we're not in a love state
if i don't love an aspect of myself it
always becomes itself right if i don't
love that aspect of myself and then i
see somebody some kind of mirroring a
reflection of that
is it actually feeling like that other
person doesn't love that aspect or is it
really just because i'm not i don't love
that aspect both
so this is this is another thing i think
makes it people very confused because we
live in this mirror hologram essentially
but in this mirror hologram it's like
the reflection is also real it's not
false it's not just a reflection so
you're seeing a perfect replica on the
external as you've got on the internal
so that means that like you know you may
reject an aspect of self but so do they
that same one or just something
different it depends on the circumstance
yeah
like i'll get i'll get more clear so
let's say that
you yourself have an issue with your
anger right
you'll be a match to somebody else who
also has an issue with anger
and so you're going to get it both from
your internal and from the external
while your internal part is like this is
not acceptable we should be able to
regulate ourselves right now you'll get
a partner who's like i'm not okay with
your anger this is really immature you
know or whatever it is so
yeah because that's familiar is that
like the like attract like kind of
situation or is it just because we find
something similar in someone else that
resonates with us no it's because we
live in a universe that's based off of
the law of miring which is what many
people call the law of attraction this
was designed as a 360 degree mirror
hologram for the sake of the perception
of expansion
so it like you cannot escape the fact
that you will see on the external
whatever is on the internal
that's an it's like a law of our time
space reality otherwise nobody would
come down to this earth so why don't
people love themselves
because of the process of socialization
so to understand that process we have to
go back to the childhood experience
where when we're in an environment like
this as a social species there's like a
code of conduct for how we have to
live so as to coexist as a group
and there are more exalted forms of this
but right now we're living in a real
shadow form of this and have been
forever where
in childhood a child has to be raised up
into this
you know position to understand what is
acceptable and what is unacceptable
what will get them rejected and what
will get them accepted
and we all go through this process with
socialization if we're part of human
society but it is that process that
teaches us what aspects of ourselves
like i said are going to get us pushed
away
and in a social group
which i think it's really important that
people accept that they're a social
species you know it's i as i go around
the planet it's been very difficult to
try to get people to under understand
what they need and what's going wrong
because they can't even see themselves
clearly you know when you're stepping in
from an outside perspective if you take
humans as a species it's a group species
it's like a herd species
and that means that the well-being of
the individual human is inseparable from
the group
this presents an issue with
socialization because our survival as
humans is so linked to our connection to
other people
that we actually will pray play like
this internal triangulation game
so as to stay connected with the people
upon whom our life depends
and so it's like what i like to do is
take people back in time to think about
themselves as a tiny infant
if i was to take a tiny infant and if i
scoop to go put them outside they're
dying
we are so
completely dependent for so long and
even when we are able to meet our needs
technically
our well-being is still dependent upon
the connection with the group
so it's important for people to first
get i am a group species
and therefore my well-being is not
independent of my connection to other
people
so in childhood when when you've got
that fundamental aspect of yourself and
that we could consider more primal
element of the
nervous system hooked into the group
when you've got mom or dad or any member
of society especially an adult who's
telling you
it doesn't need to be verbal like this
can be you know through their words
their actions through a look you know if
they're doing anything in response to us
we learn very quickly good bad right
wrong threat to me not and so when i i'm
talking about this internal
triangulation dynamic let's talk about
triangulation triangulation is
essentially where i try to establish
closeness to the exclusion of
so we see this in our social groups like
you know as girls like we've you know
how it is to kind of be like oh my gosh
you know
michelle she was like totally unfair to
you just then so it's a it's a way to
sort of push somebody away so as to
develop rapport and we have this exact
same relationship dynamic going on but
in the internal world and this is where
self-hate begins
when we perceive that an aspect of
ourselves is
not going to be accepted by the group
that we're around we push that aspect of
ourselves away so as to gain closeness
with those people in our lives
so it's an internal triangulation game
against certain aspects of self and to
the degree that we experience an aspect
of ourselves causing pain for us we will
experience the same degree of hatred
towards that part because underneath all
hatred is pain and then it's a lifelong
process of pushing that aspect away
trying to suppress it trying to deny it
trying to cut it off you know
and and this is really where we can't
stay in this integrated state we can't
take that part of us as a part of us
ourselves and that is where
you know to take that definition of love
beyond you know the other
that's where our self-love falls apart
ideally thinking that if you loved all
aspects of yourself then that would sort
of be the cure to loving others and
feeling the love of others as well i
don't like to differentiate between the
two at a certain level the point at
which to make something about the self
versus the others is the point at which
you're looking to get somebody into a
state of empowerment
there's something inherently
disempowering about depending on the
external to make a change for yourself
to feel good so that's the point at
which we start to look at at concepts
like loving myself makes it so the
external can love me but if we go to a
higher dimensional level you see that
there's actually no difference between
the external and the internal so loving
other is loving the self there is
nothing but self love
so i think it's important
to sometimes to like take the pressure
off having to love the self so as to get
love from the external even though we
recognize this mirror construct there
ultimately is no difference
it's just it would benefit us
to not be walking around in the state of
disintegration
to not be walking around in a state of
fragmentation
where we've got this internal war going
on
we're all looking for internal peace and
you also hear that especially in the
self development fields and
in the spiritual field you just hear
this like catchphrase in inner peace and
peace like all over the place and
it's like what the hell is that
that's a state where you don't have an
aspect of self against another aspect
that's a state where there's a
recognition of value in all aspects and
the integration occurs so that you can
draw from the best aspects of all of
these parts of self
and you've got a harmonious
system going on rather than
war within the system
so is the concept of trying to heal the
self heal the trauma heal the wounds
you know cultivate your relationship
with your inner child all those kinds of
things is that
an old
sort of
methodology of
of
evolving and should it really just be
shifting your consciousness to a level
that is
just accept understanding that
everything is a part of us i don't see
them as exclusive from one another
i feel like that is the most profoundly
healing step that you can take
it's just when you start to look at the
process of self-development of the
process of healing through that lens of
integration
you don't fall into as many pitfalls as
when you're focusing on i need to fix
myself or heal myself or you know do
whatever because even the process of
self-healing and the process of shadow
work can become so incredibly abusive
it can become like i need to fix this
part of mine because the background
noises because it's not okay you know
yeah when it's like it just becomes this
you're almost on the treadmill that
never ends because
you can't
hate yourself
into needing to change
and love yourself at the same time
yeah
that makes sense
well this seems like a it seems like um
i'm not gonna it sounds it feels like a
setup to fail kind of existence the
human experience really feels really
tricky and it feels like you know
there's a lot of confusion suffering and
not being able to see the self and not
being able to
understand really what's going on
there's i mean the human experience is a
whole bunch of it's your fault not mine
and and and it feels like that's just is
that the way it's designed to be
to help us grow and evolve no
what happened then where did we go wrong
resistance
human beings are more capable of going
into a state of resistance than almost
any other species and part of that is
because you could consider mankind to be
a manifestation of the mind of god let's
like say those words you know we're
looking at source which we could define
as the collective consciousness of all
things in existence
each species is essentially a
manifestation of an aspect of
what we would call source
so mind is actually what human beings
have manifested as a result of
and that makes things very tricky
because while you have all of these
amazing capacities that come along with
that you also have these incredible
shadows that come along with that
like for example you know you can see
the beauty of
being a species that has the capacity to
help source define itself
a species that has come down with this
intention of helping source become aware
you know the problem with that though is
to become aware of the self is to have
an ego so you see the human is in a
state of ego more so than almost any
other species because of this very same
trait and i think it's very important to
realize that
everything comes with contrast so every
time we have like this incredible
ability
to the flip side of that is some kind of
a shadow that can get us into a lot of
trouble and what we're seeing with
humanity is
this massive trouble
with uh you know the shadow aspect of
the manifestation of what they're what
makes them so brilliant ultimately so
where does the shadow come from
unawareness that's all the shadow is
it's not even like it comes from
anywhere it's just like what is not
exposed to to the consciousness and why
is it that we is this part of
fragmentation is that basically and when
is fragmentation a part of the shadow
like does the shadow emerge when we
fragment yes in a human yes
it's whatever so this is how to how to
put this like let's say that you're
growing up in your childhood and
anger is not okay
in your in the upbringing that you have
so you will go and do your best to
suppress deny disown
push away from your consciousness that
aspect of yourself a part of what goes
along with that is to to make it become
shadow meaning it's not what we are
conscious of anymore
and the mind essentially does that
because it's an efficiency machine
and it's trying to
it's trying to do the best that it can
with the directives that it's given so
it's like this gets us in trouble right
but the problem is like within each one
of these these shadows should we call it
is something really really
valuable we call this shadow gold so
like within your anger is the capacity
to know where your limits are with no
anger there is no limit
sure
so
so let's say you buried your limits in
the same time as you've buried your
anger and so all of a sudden you're
unaware of all your limits as well
that's going to be great in
relationships and great you know walking
around your day-to-day life and whatever
it is so yeah that process of
fragmentation that occurs as a result of
splitting off from and then suppressing
denying disowning the aspect of self
makes it go into this place within a
person where they are no longer aware of
it
that's the shadow
so one of maybe the most important
videos i've watched of yours was when
you
said the simple sentence that what you
judge you deny and i was like or
something to that degree it was a whole
whole video about that
and i have used that
and told that to so many people because
it's such a simple technique is this a
technique or what is a technique to be
able to recognize these shadow aspects
to ourselves so that we can find the
gold and we can
merge and heal these fragmented parts of
us that we don't want to we have we put
we pushed down or didn't weren't
valuable growing up it's one of the
techniques
part of again what's so difficult about
this line of work is that we have so
many different tools that we can use for
integrating the shadow we're doing we're
essentially doing shadow work using any
of these tools anytime we become
conscious of anything
so i mean some things that fit into the
realm of shadow work you can do parts
work you can do inner child work you can
do soul retrieval work you can do work
with emotions you can do breath work you
can do meditation you could do work with
shamanic medicines and all of these
could be considered working with the
shadow
so it's really about finding what's the
best tool for the person given the
specific circumstance that they're in
and there but there are some you know
tools which i consider like for just the
average joe that's not really into this
but like just to have one tool my
favorite is for them to tap into their
emotions
and i know that sounds like very
baseline but i got to tell you the
honest truth most people are walking
around not tapped into their emotions
and emotions are the carriers of
personal truth so if we have this
capacity to to practice
recognizing the somatic reaction in our
body when an emotion arises and then
essentially turning all of our attention
to that emotion so as to become intimate
with it and by intimate i mean see it
feel it hear it understand it
then what will happen is the personal
truth will essentially come into the
conscious awareness almost like a bubble
popping
like ah i see it okay so that happened
that caused me to feel this way this is
my personal truth about this
circumstance now what am i going to do
from an objective perspective about that
personal truth
i could do anything with it i could ex i
could this could be telling me you know
looking at this that i need to
communicate this it could mean that i
need to change the way i'm thinking
about this and there's all kinds of
things we could do on a mental
emotionally even physical level in
response to that personal truth
so that's the low-hanging fruit honestly
when it comes to the shadow is to pay
attention to what your emotions are
saying
yes but i don't even think that's simple
enough for some yeah to be honest i
think even just you know what are your
emotions telling you i'm pissed right
now right like i mean so then it's so
same but somebody says like i'm sad i'm
mad i mean these are this is like the
first answer right and sometimes that's
as far as it gets they can't feel their
body they don't know where it sits in
their body they
they don't know what to do next so for
someone who is new and intrigued
what is the like what is that what is
the line of questioning how do you keep
peeling it away to get down to
the core
the protocol actually should start with
only doing about a week or two weeks of
simply noticing the somatic sensations
in your body so it's it's tapping back
into the body because an emotion will
always show up on a somatic level and
oftentimes like we don't talk about this
because we just label an emotion
it's it's sort of like you know anger
may come up in terms of flushing in
terms of a sensation of constriction or
buzzing and it's those types of sensory
experiences which we need to recognize
again
and so what i the protocol i usually
give people who have an issue with this
is that i'll have them have like a
little notebook or something with them
this is the emotional notebook and for a
week or two weeks we pick depending on
what a person wants to commit to
every time they
they like set their timer for like maybe
10 minutes or like what person might do
it every hour if they have a really busy
life when that timer goes off they do a
check-in so it's almost like a very
short body scan what are the sensations
that i'm feeling in my body and then
they are writing those sensations down
and of course anytime they really know
that they're feeling a sensation like
let's get triggered or whatever the same
thing through their writing down just
the first two weeks they're just writing
down what the somatic sensation is then
the next two weeks we go and we progress
it so they become
attuned again to to the emotions within
their body as they occur
then the next step is you add the what
emotion might this be
and i'll like usually print off an
entire list for people
or have them do that themselves so they
can look at the like okay buzzing
constriction
the word that matches with this is
frustration so they'll like write down
frustration and that that's all we do
for like the next week or two weeks then
we add another layer again so we're like
making it so they're so good at this
that they can then add things without it
just becoming this cluster right sure
it's overwhelming that next
phase that next layer that we add is
is the why why am i feeling this
so it's then that they go okay so
looking back when did this come up in me
was there anything that happened in my
environment
so then they'll write it down you know
this is why i'm feeling this way and
that's a very very powerful
practice because
so many people are not even aware of the
fact that something in their life had an
effect on them in this way
yeah
so and it also helps because we're also
in this pattern you'll notice with
people just constantly emotionally
invalidating themselves so that step
helps to be like wait a minute there's a
reason why i feel emotions they just
come out of nowhere you know
and then that
but yeah then that last layer is okay so
what is the personal truth what is the
personal truth about this situation you
know it might be something like i don't
like being disrespected
okay that's interesting so there's tons
of exploration you could do there around
the disrespect
like you can you can decide from that
point there's so many choice points like
you can decide from that place of i
don't like disrespect
you can choose to go back into childhood
when was i when did i feel disrespected
in my life oh wait this is a chronic
pattern i always felt disrespected in my
life okay when was the first time and
like using that you can actually go back
and do a healing process around that
original experience
and even that will bring you closer to
personal truth and your limits and
boundaries which is you know essentially
just a firm personal truth about
who you will and what you won't be
around like what you will and won't
tolerate
also i mean another direction you could
go with that is like well was i really
disrespected
you can look at this from a more
objective perspective where it's like
you're shifting the way you're thinking
about this was i really disrespected or
was it really the you know what is the
truth of the situation is it that the
person just was in a horribly bad mood
it had literally nothing to do with me
you know
so you're sort of becoming more aware of
what the reality of the situation is and
through this exploration process you
come to
what that action step is if anything
that needs to be taken sometimes that
action step let's call it could just be
changing the way you're thinking about
the situation other times it's a
conversation that you can have but based
on doing that you're going to come at it
from a totally different place not like
screw you dude you know um you're going
to come at it from this very objective
place where it's like you're really
setting down what your truth is in that
relationship
another thing could be we take an action
that we would normally label an action
not like a conversation or like changing
the way we're thinking you know maybe i
feel disrespected
it goes beyond a conversation and you
literally
walk out the door i mean there's a
million actions you could take it's just
the goal is to become aware and
objective enough that you can really
make the right choice
yeah for yourself
is that attunement
to becoming attuned to yourself
yeah yeah
you mentioned triggers and i think that
this is a word that is some what
low-hanging fruit as well i think people
feel like this is something people have
heard of at least but they might not
really understand it and so maybe
explaining and then the role like what
what are the triggers for oh
i love this conversation okay
me too
a trigger is an emotional flashback
okay so let's talk about memory
when we experience something traumatic
memory is actually stored in a
fragmented way so fragmentation and of
itself which is this act of splitting
and and we could part of as
compartmentalizing
this act of splitting is the primary
coping mechanism for a human
and so that goes beyond just
fragmentation of parts it goes into
fragmentation of you know anything
memory is included so a memory that's
super traumatic when the brain can't
really deal with the whole thing in a
compartment it will start to separate
things out it'll start to to store the
emotional aspect of that memory separate
from the
scent aspect of that memory
visuals
and what's interesting about a physical
human is that and which is why i'm
saying that tapping back into your
emotions is one of the most important
things you can do it just which is the
low-hanging fruit when it comes to you
know this whole process of self-healing
because the emotional aspect of memory
is usually
stored closer to the conscious mind than
any other aspect
but it creates a conundrum where when's
when we experience something
that causes us to remember something
that's what we call it a trigger it's
like
oh the memory's there um
then that that
very strong emotional aspect of memory
is now back and it's like we're not
really in the current moment we're back
in the trauma and essentially getting
re-traumatized in the current moment but
a lot of us don't have any context for
that because the brain stores it in such
a separate way
so we're like what the hell is going on
with me you know the example that i like
to give is let's say that you've got a
woman who had sexual abuse and like the
let's say the man who sexually abused
her had a certain cologne he wore
so if her brain has done this and stored
everything in this way then she may be
just walking down an aisle and like
let's say another guy passes her at that
same clone out of nowhere out of nowhere
she's like
you know and it's a full-blown emotional
reaction but of course because she
doesn't have the context she's like i'm
losing my mind i'm losing my mind why am
i having a panic attack and it starts to
escalate because she's looking around
going there is nothing happening
i need to see a psychiatrist you know so
so these we all have these triggers
which are these emotional flashbacks
but what i'm trying to teach people in
the world is that there is no part of
the self which is against the self we
have to profoundly understand this in
order to get anywhere
not just with a psyche but with physical
healing as well
so if the if the body and the yourself
doesn't ever actually do anything
against you and i'm going to make that
statement very aggressively
then
what it means is that you know a
flashback even on a visual level is
trying to call you back to something
unresolved
and it's no different with a trigger a
trigger is trying to say this is
unresolved i still need help yeah you
know
so what the most powerful thing an
important thing we can do is to actually
go back to that we go back to it on a
conscious level and with choice
so as to you know figure out what we
need in order to heal from that and i
can simplify healing very quickly for
people which is to experience the
opposite so let's say that you have a
broken bone right to heal is to mend the
bone if you have
loneliness to heal might be something
like connection and there may be some
subtle variations over here based on
what somebody experienced you know for
one person who experiences this thing
that healing thing might be genuine
empowerment you know or for another
person experiencing the same thing it
might be
um
something like to have choice
but it's always something to the
opposite side of the experience it's
what they what need was not met in that
moment
and so it gives us this very
if we understand that it gives us this
very easy and understandable
um
framework for which to go oh wait what i
needed in this moment because of this
pain that i experienced is whatever this
resource is now it's about what do i do
with my mind
with my body
that makes it so that i can actualize
that the opposite of that experience
is this the rule is this a role of
polarity
is this is this what polarity is for to
get us to see things easier yes polarity
and contrast i like to use this word
contrast because
you know essentially contrast is what is
creating expansion on our planet
it is the experience of the unwanted
that pushes us in the direction of the
wanted and that movement to close that
gap is what we call growth
we couldn't perceive any of that without
it being this way so contrast is really
what gives rise to the growth experience
what gives rise to healing in the first
place
from my experience and the things that
i've gone through in my life especially
a couple years ago
and i guess in the last few years the
the more i experience something hard and
difficult and painful and
traumatic on some level
the more i feel the good it's like once
i've felt the really bad then all of a
sudden joy becomes
more accessible to me yes why the hell
does it have to work like or why does it
i mean i guess i'm grateful right
because otherwise you know
i didn't get anything for it right other
than some sort of
process that i'm learning but explain
that why is that so
the first thing i have to say to those
that universally speaking just by virtue
of having created this time space
reality source itself is in the process
of deciding whether this is the best
construct for learning
so it's not like that's going to be you
mean across like this is what's
happening right now
yeah and a lot of that is coming because
of mankind you know mankind is
questioning whether contrast is the
basis upon which all expansion must
occur whether and and what's ironic is
this question that's happening within
the mind of source as a result of
humankind questioning this to such an
extreme degree
is coming in part because you know in
this in this type of reality where
it's the external mirror you know
what we're watching is that people often
get stuck in it so instead of being able
to close that gap it's like you almost
get into this self-reinforcing loop
where the reflection makes it worse and
then that making it worse makes the
reflection worse and so it's almost like
you've got you know how this applies to
the physical life is you got a girl who
let's say it was molested in her teen
years and you know based off of that
feels distrustful around men based off
of that you know takes some sort of a
weird action and is a match to other men
that are more dangerous and then because
of that you know
let's say let's say she has to cope with
that by a sort of acclimatizing and
turning off to red flags
you know so now she doesn't notice she's
in a dangerous situation so now you've
got a girl who like not only when she's
molested at this age she's in an abusive
relationship at this age which just
makes everything worse and then you know
it escalates to the point where this is
a person who's murdered
so that dynamic that essentially is
happening as a result of this construct
just making for this big questioning but
setting that aside
that's kind of a fascinating topic in
and of itself though to be honest yeah
setting that one aside
what's important to know is that there
is no capacity to conceptualize white
without black
you actually can't
and whether that's a limit within the
mind of source or not is still to be
decided
but as of right now it's a limit that
source itself is experiencing is that
one can only know
the opposite from the context of
whatever is polar you know side is so
like you cannot know what love is
if you don't understand something like
loneliness any more than a fish can
understand what water is without the
experience of air it's not a thing you
can
understand
you know
i think a lot about like the sort of
micro macro of things and even just
talking about community and being in in
clumps of people it's like that's cells
when you scientists look at how cancer
works it's loss of cell communication
and then i look at like the universe and
i think to myself
where are we're growing and expanding
the universe is growing and expanding
and it just all seems like there's some
sort of micro macro like it's just some
sort of
frequency vibration game that's just
i don't know reverberating
um
um
mathematically properly across all
different planes i don't know i it's
just something i think about does that
make any sense yeah the mathematics of
the universe is based on fractals and
fractals is exactly what you're
describing i love fractals
what is what would blow i mean
i look at this all the time i remember
you know walking down the beach and just
seeing
how the water
drains off
into the ocean and how it just looks
like a canyon
in a mountain range right and you're
like
this is just like the small version of
the big version
um so
maybe just like how does fractals play
in what could what could you what could
you tell us that's fractal in nature
maybe other than everything it's
everything
everything
so what what are we like what is this
experience what is
what is what are we here for then well
are you talking about
like life itself
i guess because if everything's just
fractal in nature and it's just sort of
perfect geometry happening all over the
place it
i'm wondering where consciousness plays
into it and our existence and what we're
essentially here for
why are we even able to quantify or
question this
because source itself is trying to know
itself
and i i think this is one of the most
freeing answers
if people really understand it but it's
also a terrifying answer it's like you
know that there's a terror in freedom
and there's a terror in responsibility
and there's a terror for humans if they
start looking at this concept of source
or god as if it's not this all-knowing
being that already has everything
planned out
when p when humans understand the source
itself has a subconscious
and does not know itself
it's like oh no we're out on a limb but
it gets even scarier when i tell you
that every creature that has ever been
you know created in existence you know
source is all there is so it's
essentially taking parts of itself and
like let's see all of the potentials of
me so as to become self-aware so we are
facilitating the self-awareness within
source itself
isn't that what we're our journey to
yes for the same journey because
a fractal of source
and so
what's the end game for that
why would we know
well the game will be over
i get it
what would be over what is oh what is
over okay so i'm gonna do you want me to
catch you up to where sources right now
are you interested in that love that i
would love that
so so source as a collective mind let's
say it is in a place where it it has
basically it's fragmented because of the
concept of i
like you know what am i uh oh you know
that word i essentially created this
mass fragmentation within itself where
each element of that fragment itself is
a fractal of itself right
so what's really important to know about
source is that it's it's kind of gone
with this process of like all right so
let's see how many different aspects of
myself i can create so as to see what i
am and then it realizes wait a minute
in the act of even creating these
i am deciding what i am and that is a
never-ending process so sources are
ready to the place where it realizes
there's no end to this it's no end to
what it can create and therefore there
is no end to what it is it's an infinite
game now once source became aware of the
fact that it was an infinite game it's
like wait a second
so then
if there's no end to this
and i'm just creating whatever it is
that i could perceive in myself
then
the only reason once we come back to a
state of of integration that means all
you know one source fragments
the elements of source are imbued within
these fractals
and this is a big problem in the
universe right now because free will is
an element of source
and so when it fragmented free will was
an element of all the aspects of itself
so it doesn't matter whether the overall
sort of has this understanding
that process of fragmentation made it so
that each element must choose with its
free will back into that state of
oneness
so this is why we're still in this game
even after source itself as this
collective has realized this
is because just because source realized
it doesn't mean that all aspects of
itself are on board with that yet they
are still choosing separation but that
aside
you know sources at this place where
it's like
you know if the game really isn't to
know myself because that's an infinite
game whatever i create i am then the
only reason essentially to create after
the process of reintegration
is by choice
i choose what i am
and what are we i mean that's as far as
sources right now it's just right it's
just at that point in time and what if
it decides that um what if source
decides that choosing is not fun
it's um
i could just keep choosing forever
what's the point i mean i if the source
is literally at the point where that's
not even a question like if you have a
choice in the act of choice you would
never choose something that isn't fun so
like that question almost doesn't exist
in a position of choice i think i see
but like you know essentially the source
is not at the place where it has
reintegrated to see what all of it
collectively will choose together
so it's it's had this realizations and
now it's stuck quote unquote in this
process of trying to get all these
fragmented aspects of self to choose
back to a state of oneness so that it
can make an integrated choice about what
it is and what its next step is
is is that aspect playing out in us as
well as far as choice and choosing we're
all trying to decide
are we going to come together and
because the universe got to this point
already
the level of pressure cooker this is why
most of us were nervous i mean
ultimately looking from a higher
perspective things are a little
different you get up there and you look
down you're like wow it's beautiful okay
so
um that's not how it feels in the
physical the way it feels in the
physical is one source is like wait a
minute i'm now in a position where all
aspects of me have to choose back into a
state of oneness so i can make an
integrated choice
oh man was the heat turned up like ah
you know just
to the point where the
pressure being put on like each
individual aspect
to choose out of a state of what we call
narcissism to choose out of this this
egoic state where there is a separated
self-hood
that that kind of has a well-being
separate from the collective
that's like not even a choice you can
make it anymore without consequences so
high that you know from here in your
physical life you're just kind of like
what bed do i hide under you know but
yeah we're in a pressure cooker right
now and everybody is being forced to
choose
so going to the smaller fractal which is
you and your individual life
each person in within this
system right now is being put in a
position to have to choose
are you going to continue to play a
zero-sum game are you going to continue
to act like a cancer cell
there will be consequences but it's not
personal it's like a mirror it's like
you're going to act that way
then let's see the consequences because
there's we live in it we live in a cause
and effect face universe you can't get
out of that it's not even personal it's
not like sources like this mother or
father figure that's like huh you know i
really don't think that was great of you
so here's your punishment i'm telling
you it's not like that it's just you
know in a mirror-based hologram if you
behave in a way that is to not consider
the other have fun with a life where you
are not considered
so that's the choosing yep that's the po
that's the point we're at that's the
choosing you can choose to
play along or or integrate or
or not
yeah
and so
for those who decide not to
is
what is that outcome versus
um and maybe this kind of plays into a
question i have that i've heard about um
or for the people who decide to
integrate is this
part of a new earth is that even a real
thing what what is this real thing yes
it's a part of the new earth and it's a
very real thing
if you're a person who essentially
chooses separation that's the choice
room if you're a person who chooses
separation the level of suffering that
you will experience
is
extreme
and you will potentially be choosing
death
because you're you're essentially making
a choice to stay out of alignment with
the rest of source you know when source
makes a movement it like all of the
fractals of itself are now in this
pressure cooker to create the same
movement if you don't do that you're
against the current of the universe so
that creates massive amounts of
suffering and if you don't close that
gap quick enough it means death which is
why we're headed towards this very
difficult time period where so many
people will be choosing off of earth you
know and not even like when i say
choosing i don't even mean on like a
conscious level it's a very like
subconscious choosing it's not like
people are saying i want this it's just
sort of determinism yeah yeah and and
like sources in a position
which everybody is when they're dealing
with a genuine narcissist which is like
i can do nothing with this like you've
decided for a bubble everything i tell
you you won't take in you're going to
reframe everything so it's like you're
having to essentially let them go so far
off by themselves that eventually that
state causes so much pain that they
choose with their own free will to come
back you can't chase them anymore it's
almost like you have to give them
permission to separate so far
just becoming a more extreme
version of the game yep
okay so let's let's talk about how this
plays into the new earth
if people are putting this pressure
cooker and they choose you know what i'm
sick of this say separation i am sick of
this
crap i'm sick of suffering
like what i'm wanting is to become fully
conscious what i'm wanting is to become
integrated with the rest of the system
and when i say that i i don't just mean
humanity i mean the system of the earth
we're living on and ultimately the
system of the universe itself
then we step into what people are
calling this new earth which is
essentially the conscious humanity so
when we're talking about the new earth
we're talking about the final state of a
redeemed humanity now a lot of different
um cultures have been talking about that
a lot of different religions have been
talking about that but what i look at
with the new earth is these three
qualities the first being renovation the
first being restoration or second being
restoration the third being this
restructuring
and these three r's make it so that the
the painful qualities of your human
existence we could say suffering we
could say you know a christian might
call it sin which is to be out of
alignment you know sin sin was actually
originally um
something that came from archery like to
sin this to miss the mark huh so so
those of us who are not really into the
sort of christian narrative who are more
into the spiritual narrative you can
look at the concept of sin as being out
of alignment with something
so it's our our capacities are sorry our
issue with being out of alignment with
the greater system is something that
does not exist in the state of the new
earth so that's the absence of sin the
absence of of suffering and some even
project the absence of death
and that's a potential
there is some value to be held in the
switching of perspectives but if you are
so in alignment that you're constantly
lining up with the expansion path there
is no reason for death so what you see
is the exalted form of the human
and this exalted form of the human is
reflected within society and when you
have the exalted form of the human
society you have what so many people
call utopia it's nothing more than a
conscious humanity where the delusion of
separateness is no longer exist is this
something where we all live on the same
planet together
physically yeah consciously in a
different place
yes and the reason that i say that is
because
the people who are talking about this
concept of the new earth not being
something that takes place physically on
earth or in resistance to physicality
source itself is not in resistance to
physicality there is so much ecstasy to
be experienced in the physical life you
know and it's just going to get better
the same is like if i was to take you
right now and put you back in the 1600s
and to see what the medical practices
are back then you're like yeah you know
it's barbaric so to that to them in that
age this seems like a dream
and i and i'm like sort of trying to
explain that sort of the pain that we
have with our physical experience
doesn't really exist in this new earth
experience
because like even if they're if you were
to get out of alignment you know we're
looking at progress in the future and
that's not even all the way to the new
earth like progress in the future where
you get sick and literally you pass
through a light that's able to reset
everything
there's no pain involved in this process
it's oh today i manifested cancer cells
i passed through this light now they're
gone you know and stuff that most of us
cannot conceptualize on from this place
that we're in today it makes me think of
some stories that i've heard from other
people about
extraterrestrials and things that have
come to earth that they were supposed to
build and then it didn't get to happen
and things like that and so then it
makes me wonder about
about the role
about
i'm guessing extraterrestrials exist
other entities
yes
um i figured that was the case um i
didn't want to assume so what is their
role then what did what is their role in
our evolution it depends on the one yeah
so let's go let's go i'll just i'll give
an overview but i mean
it's important for people who are
watching this to know that we're greatly
simplifying concepts for the sake of you
know people being able to understand
things so
yeah this is like in and of itself its
own
a rabbit hole but
i might take you a little ways down the
rabbit hole
we'll start here and we'll just see how
many people we can keep on board
see how long i can stay on board okay oh
i think you have a great capacity for
that one
all right so when it comes to
extraterrestrials it's a it's really
like across the map what level of
consciousness these beings have and what
role they're playing within the greater
universe
you have what we call a malevolent being
universally speaking is not necessarily
a malevolent being and this is what's
hard for people to grasp
and the way that i kind of spell this is
i can have argument about this but i'm
going to i'm gonna just throw this out
there's not a perfect example but
you've probably heard people saying it's
really important for us to weed a
certain population of species out here
otherwise the earth's gonna get in
trouble
do you think that we are the villain to
that species or the victor even though
we see ourselves this way
we're the villain right we're the bad
guy we're the one that's coming in and
saying i get to be like we're wrecking a
lot of things we are but like we see
ourselves oftentimes as as doing
something beneficial
whereas that's not what is
being perceived by whatever species is
doing their thing
wow
so so the first story that i'm going to
essentially tell you about is this the
story where there's extraterrestrial
beings who are considered like universal
scavengers or part of the universal
immune system
okay now if you have a species that is
behaving like a bacterial infection
then it gets targeted by the immune
system of the universe at large which
just so happens to be you know that we
could consider like a t cell
within source to be one of these
extraterrestrial beings
so they they essentially target a
species that's so
acting its own best interest against the
rest of the system that it comes in and
essentially tries to take it out
at the same time as you have an
extraterrestrial being who's like you
know what there's so much value in
humanity we can make humanity choose so
even they are playing into this choice
point where you've got you know these
extraterrestrial beings we're trying to
prove that
the human race is essentially gone rogue
and as a clean up species meaning it's
one enough to take out of the picture of
the rest of the system because to be
honest with you right now
the amount of collective asking from
earth
from other species
planting the mineral kingdom animal
kingdom that are asking for us to go
is huge it's like a
signal throughout the universe right
not good at the same time as you're
having like a whole whole like other you
know form of extraterrestrial beings and
this is more complicated which has
reached this level of awareness in
general where they understand that there
is nothing in the universe that is not
it and so when there's this
distress call being made by things
around a being that you also are
there's an inherent desire to bring that
aspect back into alignment because you
don't see it as separate to oneself
so there's essentially a war this bigger
war being waged over humanity but it's
not a traditional war
it's the war over what will they choose
if there's influence
so you've got these extraterrestrial
beings trying to influence humanity to
like prove
that you know they're they are a garbage
species essentially that's causing
problems in the greater universe and
world and you know this whole group
which is trying to put influence on
humans to to prove that they're capable
of being like wait i'm not going to act
like a cancer cell i'm going to tune
back into the system and essentially
create a win-win which they're so
capable of doing
so how do these fighter t cells or
whatever we want to call them how do
they get us to try and essentially be
wiped out manipulating the media
but what's important to know is they're
not controlling people they're putting
pressure on people
these extraterrestrial beings no matter
it doesn't matter what et you talk to
right
all of them understand the concept of
free will and choice all of them have to
operate within this you know the primary
laws that govern our universe like law
of attraction which is why you know you
there's no such thing as like a what we
call a gray there's no such thing as a
gray alien is from zeta reticuli there's
no such thing as them coming in and
doing an abduction on somebody who
hasn't already experienced some form of
powerlessness at the hands of an abuser
or whatever doesn't happen
so they're still they're operating
within you know the rules within this
greater universe they can't not they
understand choice
so so it's like they're not able to
control you neither they're able to
influence
so they're going to influence through
you know anything that makes the
humanity go towards the ego things like
fear things like you know greed things
like envy you know all of these
experiences that can catch people and
cause them to you know separate at the
same time as you've got the other ones
who are essentially like no love no tune
into people no you know
and we're kind of seeing where humanity
kill yourself feel your emotions yeah
like i don't have time i got this other
thing going on i'm my ego's calling
it feels like an ego game it feels like
i i think about this war within myself
of you know
the the ego is really impatient and it's
all the the give me now and protect
myself i mean i think there's a positive
role for the ego too because it's just
learned from a young age that if certain
things play out in life it might go
poorly and since we're an efficiency
machine we just know how to negate
against it and keep ourselves happy in
this very little moment even though next
week or next year or 10 years down the
road you're really super screwed
and that on the other side of it the the
the
the the benevolent voice the ones that
want to see us succeed it's quiet
right that's a much more quiet voice
it's a much less
pushy it's um it's not anxious it it
that dynamic is hard that that that that
it's the ego game that is a that is a
that is a clawing game and in fact
makes me think of certain times where i
feel like i've had egoic deaths along
the way
there's a like a like a one or two
rounds of like a last chance clawing and
it really seems like that where these
weird like talons come out and you say
and do things that you're like the hell
was that like i've made so much progress
that was terrible and it feels like
there's like this vicious coming for you
and is that is that a phase that we're
in where we just need to like
endure this sort of vicious phase that's
happening where
this division and this sort of choice
game is really challenging we have to
embrace the fact that there is this
massive challenge of the pressure cooker
of this awakening that i'm describing
but what what we must do is to
aggressively love the ego
and that's what nobody's doing and it's
a struggle for me even because you know
english language again when i'm here
telling you that the ego is doing
something super bad the natural
reflection for a human is to be like all
right then we gotta push the ego away
well that's how it wins right there and
and it's not even about a wing losing
game the ego is incredibly beneficial
but unless we really spend time to
understand it and figure out how to meet
its needs and by doing so come in as a
kind of like you know i'm caretaking the
ego as a tool of my own rather than it's
the thing that runs me
we're not going to be able to make this
transition happen
how do we do that how do we how do we
make friends with the ego how do we love
the ego how do we understand the ego
you understand the value of having self
you understand the value of the aspects
of self
and by virtue of understanding the value
you know what place to put it in you
know
i think the recognition of the ego is
the first step you know most people it's
like it's a very complicated prop you
know practice it's like you can look at
buddhist monks for example you've got
people who have taken themselves out of
society put themselves in a monastery
and they're practicing this for 80 years
straight
so it's even more difficult when you're
in the world and you've got so many
triggers for the ego but the recognition
of the ego which is this perception
separate self is the first step
to recognize when any aspect of you is
fighting for self
in any way
and to not make that wrong it's just the
recognition you know and that's what we
call that that external witnessing or
the the some people call this detachment
or disidentification
people say interesting i am watching
teal you know if i'm doing me i am
watching teal
have a a reaction to the fact that this
person
has achieved something i have not
achieved
what does that tell me about myself and
it's like you're almost approaching it
like you would
i don't want to like belittle the ego by
saying it's like a child but
there's a very loving way you can
approach a child when it's in that state
how do i empower the self so it's not in
the state where it's grasping you know
how do i sit with my emotions to allow
myself to understand that the way that
it feels makes sense
and it all of this process causes a
calming down of in the integration of
the ego and so what we end up with
eventually is the conscious ego which
most people don't
understand as a state that exists most
people think consciousness is when you
get rid of the ego i think it's the
worst thing we've ever taught honestly
wow like we're trying to progress to a
place where
the conscious ego is a choice selfhood
is a choice so
the the whole concept of self is
something which you can put on and you
can take off and you can choose elements
of and you can extract from and it's
this relationship to the self-hood that
is very much like it's not something
that stuck to me
the word that kept coming to mind as you
were talking is observer i think you
might have even said observe and i
think of that for my own life and just
when i'm in observer mode which i want
i i'd love for you to talk about that
and what that is and how we can access
that i feel so
much more peace and then i started
thinking this is almost feels like
almost like re-parenting in a way like
how would you if you were
if we look at the ego as a little child
like i'm thinking almost like a
re-parenting but you get to do it
instead of someone else doing it exactly
of course you're gonna do it in a loving
way and everything's gonna be okay that
they do because it's really just a
learning process exactly
and that it's exactly like that it's a
re-parenting process of the you know the
aspect of self that is fighting for the
self in any moment but where you this
there's so many pitfalls see it's like
the next pitfall is if if in that
attitude of re-parenting there's any
patronization of the ego it's already
done see so
i think this is kind of what makes it
fun don't get me wrong it sucks a lot
but like it's also what makes it fun is
that there's just like ah
there i was again you know
just in the act of like even being in
this attitude of like i'm gonna come in
and help you i'm
in the ego god
it's like you keep getting stuck
it's like you keep and that this human
experience is just so fascinating okay
observer because i think this is a huge
i've found so much benefit even even if
i have to
actively choose like hang on let me take
a deep breath let me try and literally
and i literally try and look i'm just
looking at the scenario i'm from a
visual standpoint i'm that's how i get
the observer i just observe and i
observe myself sitting there and the
other person's sitting there and
but how how can we like what is the role
of the observer and how can we
practice it and how can we
cultivate a
more
time in that space when we practice the
observer perspective we're taking in
more of the objective truth of the
situation
the way to make this make sense is that
i want you to imagine that all things in
existence so let's just take people for
right now like if i have five people in
the room right now
the pers the perception from inside
that's the eye the ego the perception
from inside of a subjective perspective
is like when we step into one camera
lens
like let no let's go here let's imagine
that you've got a telescope
and a telescope is set up here and then
another telescope is set up over there
and another telescope is set up over
there they're all going to be looking at
different angles
they're all actually right
from the angle where they are and the
observer though is where you are able to
step up outside of that
to take in a more objective perspective
the one that's capable of saying ah
that's why this one sees it in this way
that's why this one sees it this way and
then you know ultimately the even more
where this graduates to is the capacity
to step into and out of any subjective
perspective so as to get the objective
overall truth
but
that being aside because it's one of
those really like far down the spiritual
road sort of practices
if we have the capacity to not be so
attached to our own telescope in a
moment we can zoom up we will take in
more information about the reality of
what's happening than we have available
to our consciousness and these confines
and that information changes everything
i mean everything
and if it and if the information changes
it changes the way that we react to a
situation it changes the actions we
ultimately take i feel like almost like
i was just thinking about our own inner
lens like
a telescope or camera or anything like
that right we have our own personal lens
and i was thinking i feel like it's like
the lens is like the ego but it's it's
great because it's spotlighting stuff
it's like checking it out really closely
it's like hang on alert alert and yes
it's like huge it's like no that's an
ant it's not a problem um
and that and that the the observer is
playing like the the the ego and the
observer
connect because there's still
information and it feels like our lens
the ego is really important to see
what's going on and scan but the
observer goes no little little timmy
it's okay it's it's just an ant it's
it's it's a little timmy let me give you
some well that's sort of condescending
see there we are again but like
damn it
keeps catching it it basically tells
that it tells that aspect of self here's
some information that you don't see yet
right which changes the way that that
that aspect perceives subjective life
but i'm so glad you went here because
it's so important to understand that
there's different information available
at a subjective than an objective
perspective the objective perspective
has more of the objective truth but
what's so interesting and what i love
the ego about so much is that when you
step fully into somebody's subjective
perspective that's a whole other realm
of information that comes out of that
you know and i it's like one of my
favorite things actually is to spend
time in these other subjective
perspectives in the universe
because it's like you can't see some of
the stuff from a bird's-eye view
like you may be able to see the bigger
picture better but like some of those
nuances and intricacies you don't see
until you're in someone's
lens you know
now you have a gift for that lens yeah
how does someone else do that
someone that doesn't have that you know
that that level of a gift or that
ability to be able to see
as easily this human experience is
challenging
they commit to understanding above
anything else
and i'm sort of dropping these ideas out
understanding that the practice of them
is much more difficult than
us sitting here and talking about it
but it will blow your mind when you
start to commit to the practice of
understanding how much we don't do this
so it's it's i mean to approach other
people especially because that's what
we're going to primarily be dealing with
i want to start there and have people
graduate out from there right we're
going to start with people
for me to walk into any circumstance and
be in a space of understanding
i have to take the aspect of me that
wants to be understood it's still a very
important part and sort of table it for
a minute because if it's like i want you
to understand me
then i i i'm not even looking at you
right i'm just like this is what i need
you to know yeah you're not even
thinking about them your mind is
somewhere else they could be talking you
don't even know because your train of
thought is with understanding is the
opposite type of mentality you're
walking in
trying to and wanting all the
information and i'm when i say all the
information i mean on all levels i want
to be able to feel it i want to be able
to see it i want to be able to hear it i
want to be able to conceptualize of it
and if that's a goal of mine then i must
first perceive there to be some personal
benefit for doing so
and there always is once you get to that
place of like there's a personal benefit
and understanding it's like you're open
you're walking in almost like the
exalted form of a scientist where it's
like
the first thing that i want to do
is to see more
is to hear more
feel more and then you start this
process of like asking questions
and through that process even if you
can't you know do what someone like me
can do which is to literally go out and
go into someone um
what they will be doing is painting a
picture of what they're seeing through
their lens yeah
and then even that that information
changes even some things i'm doing over
here with me you know like
my truth i was about to just bring in
and slam in your face like it changes
some of this even right because i'm
seeing things from a more objective
perspective that changes the way i deal
with you my understanding of anything
changes the way you interact with
something you know
i'm sorry anybody who's really good at
something knows what this is like you
know
if you lack the understanding there are
mistakes that you will make
if you have the understanding you're not
going to make those mistakes this leads
me into um relationships and how they
really you know just thinking about this
dynamic it's plays out i feel like most
most prevalent in relation relationships
what's the what is sources i mean
might all be the same but what is there
a specific role for relationships
partnerships oh god there's nothing
nothing bigger for self-awareness in
existence right and from from i mean i'm
going to say i don't even go beyond that
because from
source perspective if you ask a person
what is life
life is nothing more than relationships
what you call my life
is my relationship to anything in this
existence with me my relationship to my
cup my relationship to this person my
relationship to my job as a concept
there is nothing that is not
relationships so you know if
relationships are life there you go and
life was designed to essentially create
self-awareness within source so
no better platform than relationships to
learn about oneself is that because it's
the most we're the most emotional we're
the most vulnerable no it's because we
get to see ourselves
and you know i we can talk about
relationships between
people but i would like i'm saying like
relationships is much broader than that
sure
like even the relationship to one's
career i'm just gonna say someone's job
i mean that's a huge thing in people's
lives if your to your job teaches you
about yourself it's only by um
understanding oneself in that
circumstance where we're put in the
position to have to that you can even
progress
in a relationship whether that's with
your career or with another person
it's quite brilliant when you think
about it
i wish it felt better sometimes
i mean i i'm eternally fascinated by the
you know concept of
soul groups and
twin flames and
soul mates and and all of that and what
kind of energy is that in the universe
oh all right so remember how we were
talking about these fractals
so you can you can treat anything in the
universe as a singularity you can so
like let's say that like i i look at you
most of the time i don't but like
and the average person looks at you as
an eye as a thing
that's not technically the truth of you
you are more like an ecosystem that we
are calling by one name
and this just this fractal concept just
keeps going out now and out and out so
when we talk about a soul family
we're calling it by one name but it's a
system of beings
and they all resonate at a specific
frequency which is why they can be
grouped together but we're essentially
creating these groups by witnessing them
it's not like they exist in and of
themselves you know if we look at the
whole ocean and we say oh this is the
east australian current it's like but
it's the ocean yeah it's something we're
creating a differentiation between this
aspect of the ocean and other aspects of
the ocean it's inherently like something
that we are doing
but let's say that there are qualities
that make it so we can group it in that
way
and for like for the current it's like
well we can see that here all of the
water is going this way instead of this
way and that's what makes this different
than this
so anytime we're talking about you know
these soul groups or whatever it is on
that level we're treating as a system as
if it's one entity
and that overall entity in itself will
have like an intention oftentimes or a
purpose the same as a human would have
spontaneously arrives is this some
agreement before you incarnate oh it's
always an agreement when we're talking
about soul families and all these types
of it's always before you came in what
does that look like the process of
deciding things before you come into
this life yeah oh it's very difficult
for it for a human mind i'm going to try
to get you as close as i can because one
thing we have to understand is that the
human mind has its limits and it was
actually designed to have its limits
like it was designed to plug into the
physical time space reality in a very
specific way because that perception
benefits it but of course there is like
a downside to that which is very
difficult for a human mind for example
that is designed to perceive time which
is linearity to understand the concept
of there is no
there is no linear anything in the
universe see this heart like i can talk
about it as a concept it's very hard to
kind of yeah and that experience before
coming into this life is the same thing
because when you die you're the stream
of energy which you have identified as
yourself it withdraws from the physical
and it also withdraws from what we would
call a thought form so that now it is
essentially part of you know the source
construct again and so it is in this
incredibly objective perspective and
it's i'm not going to be able to get a
person
with a human brain translating this
experience to understand what the
objective perspective of source is like
it might you know i can just get us
close
because from that place there is there
is no identification like you experience
it today and from that perspective
you're not limited like we are limited
down here by the human mind
so you can look at all of these time
space reality potentials as a result of
going into anything so it gets as
complicated as let's say that you're
looking at your mother and she has 45
viable eggs
like you're b you're going to be doing
this for like multiple parents at the
same time but just to blow your mind
let's say that you decide to zoom in on
just one woman you're looking at 45
viable eggs meaning that they're the
only potentials that exist in her life
with a partner is that there's only 45
eggs that will potentially be fertilized
in this woman's lifetime
you're looking literally at what what
one of those 45 potentials are
and what all the potentials branching
off from that partner which you would be
a match to at that particular time would
be
to look at what experience that gives
rise to in your life
and then and i'm just talking about the
process of fertilization not any other
experience she goes through in her life
not the impact or the changes that will
be made by virtue of you coming into her
body you can look at all of it at the
same time
it's
like it's more like a computer just you
know downloading
what dimension is that
usually when we're when we're looking at
those types of potentials we're more
engaging like at the ninth dimensional
frequency rather than 11 through 12.
it's just so high it's so complicated
yeah i mean
i get what you're saying okay
i get what you're saying and i'm just
curiou i mean i i've had someone exp
someone explain to me uh you know time
dimensions and just essentially well
actually maybe just
explain dimensions i feel like this is
people hear about you know 3d 4d 5d but
like is there a way that you can kind of
lay out
um
and how many are there i'm
there are 12 ultimately in this universe
and that 12th dimension is where
essentially everything is one again
what's important to know it's not really
important to know what is at each
dimension for a person what's important
to know is that how these different
dimensional frequencies work is like a
massive version of that aperture or
telescope difference i'm talking to you
about it's like at these different
levels there is a completely different
perceptual reality and different laws
that apply
for example in our time-space reality in
the physical dimension you really are
tied to this one incarnation
and you will experience the progression
over the timeline of your one
incarnation
once we get up to the fourth and fifth
dimension fifth dimension is really
where this falls apart once you get into
the fifth dimension
the concept of time
falls apart and all of a sudden you have
access suddenly you're still in your own
personal timeline meaning teal right in
this incarnation however you're not
limited according to one linear timeline
based off of where you are you can
switch so the way that the fifth
dimension works more like is what you
see in back to the future
only you don't need a car for it it's
like literally you can go back in time
and you can make a different choice and
experience a whole different timeline
simultaneously
so you get to play with awareness yes
with awareness with awareness so you get
to pick your inflection points
wow yeah so like i mean there's all i
mean this is the thing like i could
for all these different dimensions
there's all these different properties
that come with that but what's important
for a person who's on the path of
spirituality is to understand that
accessing these different
you know these different
frequencies of awareness which is also
what it is is the capacity to access
information at a different or not just
information experiences and different
laws that exist at these different
levels
you know so it's like the limitation
goes
d you sort of down down down down down
down the further up you go
and then but you start to see the value
in the sort of the focus we call it
focus so here's the experience that has
a limitation from the higher
dimensionals looking down we experience
that as you choosing a specific focus
for a reason
which is really fabulous
it's another thing that i've thought
about a lot is that
it's some maybe chaos theory is the word
for it where you look at something and
it seems disorganized it seems like
chaos but in my mind i'm like i think
it's just because you're looking too
close like once you pull back far enough
and i you know everything takes a
certain amount of
pulling back but is that true yeah
there's no chaos from a from a higher
level at all you know
the genu if you want to say that
anything is chaos it's the state of
determinism that's the chaos
but there's a certain order to that even
it's the most predictable thing
determinism is the most predictable
thing but that's the chaos because it's
it's a action that's absent to free will
wow i just went way up there didn't i
okay no no that's okay i'm gonna ask one
last question and it's kind of a selfish
one but i'm just curious and maybe it
will resonate with other people out
there who have had some experiences but
um you know it's kind of this you know
experience of something
out of body something
some transcendental moment some
spiritual moment whatever someone wants
to give for it and will use me as an
example
maybe give some insight to people what
they might be experiencing so i
have this experience i'm gonna try and
make this short and sweet um
i have this experience i'm in tulum
mexico
i have i meet this dog and i name the
dog and then i say the dog i think the
dog is me i don't even know why i'm
saying this and that when i'm there
and about three or four days into the
trip
um i go down to the beach i'm trying to
find a place to lay on the beach and i
told my friend i was gonna try and find
a new spot where there was some sunshine
because it was the afternoon but i've
migrated all the way back to the
original spot where we you know laid all
week and i sat down and this dog sat
down next to me and all of a sudden i
just don't know where i went and i don't
know if my eyes were open closed i don't
know how long it was but i had this
feeling where there's just like it felt
like an energy shaft like an energy it
was it was just like an energy shaft
that went up sort of diagonally from me
and it was this awareness of love it was
this awareness of
total and complete
perfect perfect love and it wasn't that
there was there was no matter how far i
went no matter how long i was gone no
matter how removed i was from this
connection that it was never gone and it
was always okay and there was there's no
need for forgiveness because there was
never judgment in the first place
and then i came to and i just bawled for
like an hour
and i just i've never known what it was
it was just the most mystical experience
and maybe other people have had
something like that that was a twin
flame
oh
okay so it's it's important whenever
we're having these conversations and
we're using a specific word to make sure
that you're meaning the same thing as
the other person because a lot of people
they don't use twin flame in the same
way that i do
when i'm talking about twin flame
relationship that's essentially a split
soul so one of the hardest things for us
to conceptualize i remember i said we
think of ourselves as the one thing
is that
these these streams of consciousness
that we identify as the soul function
more like water they can fragment so
many times which is why the conversation
about past lives is really a complex one
because in this life the chances of your
soul stream incarnating in only one
incarnation is incredibly rare most of
the time a person's soul stream is
incarnated here and here and here and
here and here and not just as humans
so part of that experience when you knew
this dog was you is that you understood
this was a fragment of your soul stream
now that would have been perfectly
planned and orchestrated based off of
what was happening prior to that in your
life that this aspect of yourself this
other aspect meets you and there is an
absolute knowing of what is beyond your
singularity in this life what is built
beyond that egoic state is that we are
one above this and so the meeting with
that thing caused an instantaneous
you're not stuck in this physical
dimension remember what's outside this
dimension where you got all of that
awareness through your being and no
longer felt alone for the first time
yeah
wow
thank you for clarifying that that's
beautiful
now
that dog and then that dog goes i don't
get to hang out i don't get my twin
flame my twin flame came in as a dog in
this life
well why does the twin flame we see this
is this is where i need to sort of like
make a i need to sort of split hairs
here because
a lot of people are when they when they
use that word twin flame they're talking
about like a person who you're supposed
to be meeting as a mate
sure
this is not like when you get into this
higher perspective that's not
necessarily what a twin flame is i mean
you could your twin flame could be a
grass blade at the same time as another
aspect could be a dog at the same time
the next person could be a person
sometimes
your overall intention for coming into
this life is that at a certain point you
will meet
the split soul in the form of the
opposite gender or if you're you know it
could be even a homosexual relationship
where it's it's still the split soul
that's a very specific contract though
like that is a contract that it's not
like everybody should be looking for the
twin fund i'll tell you that
because it can get just as intense as it
can be wonderful
you know because it's like i mean it's
almost like for the people who opt into
a romantic relationship with a twin
flame element of self
oh get ready to be triggered off your
ass like
you know
it's one of those things where you're
going to be looking at yourself
everything you hate and love and it's a
very explosive relationship
but i i want people sort of separate
this meaning that they add it's humans
that have this concept that a twin flame
should always be a life mate
can be something else oh yeah oh and you
can even have a quick playing in an
antagonist no you have many that's going
to be anything so it can be a person it
can be a dog but it might be in other
dimensions the likelihood of you and
another aspect of you
meeting in this life is very in this
life are very are very high very high
okay but the question is are you going
to recognize it because you know you you
it was very you were very fortunate to
be in a position where
in order to have the type of experience
you had
you would already have to be on this
path enough to be open enough that you
could recognize it yeah the recognition
doesn't often occur
and so oftentimes you know somebody
who's in my position i could be watching
oh that's another fragment of that
person's soul and they're like i hate
that person you know
or they don't even recognize it they
walk right by the tree that was
something i actually visually washed in
the park in new york they were like a
per there was a tree in central park
that was literally a fragment of this
one person i have only ever seen that
one time but i mean just totally
oblivious walked right by the tree and
the tree was like
reaching i mean they're just reaching
out towards this woman and it's just me
you know so
you you just sort of have to be in a
frequency to recognize in the first
place
but i don't i want people to understand
that like that the ultimate dynamic
that's happening with the twin flame is
that splitting of what we call that soul
stream
which means you are genuinely i mean in
a much more intense way meeting a
version of self you know
everyone's you at the higher level but
like that's a really intense sort of
focused version of that
and if and we need to like we need to
remove our the human meaning we've added
to it
to understand that we may be interacting
with a split aspect of our own soul
stream anywhere you know and and it's
very common that a soul stream will send
down multiple aspects of itself into
different incarnations at the same
timeline because think about it if we're
after awareness
isn't it so great to put yourself in
this perspective at the same time as
this perspective in the same sort
sure it's the ultimate learning
experience yeah
but learn like growth is painful
yeah
wow all right well thank you for that
hope and that beautiful um understanding
and for your wisdom
and um
yeah i i'm just really grateful i've
learned a lot from you thank you so much
and you're welcome thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button